bonjour à tous je m'appelle charles
merlin et je suis co fondateur du
ministère du bonheur je suis venu vous
parler de bien-être et je n'ai pas conçu
mon intervention en respectant les codes
d'un talk classique
vous n'entendrez pas une histoire
personnelle inspirante ou un héros
rencontrent un obstacle le surmonte et
en ressort transformé
non j'ai fait le choix de sortir du
cadre et de vous proposer un plaidoyer
c'est une conviction que je veux
partager avec vous qui est forte
celle d'intégrer le bien-être au coeur
de l'orientation et de l'évaluation des
politiques publiques de nos
gouvernements
on n'a pas donné explique heures je sais
pas si c'est ça ok
je vais essayer de faire ça en apportant
un regard neuf et en vous apportant des
exemples bien concrets
je vous inviterai juste à une chose à
prendre beaucoup de recul vu le contexte
actuel
la grève sncf les blocages dans les
universités notre dame des landes le
terrorisme le sujet est lié à tout ça
mais je vous invite à prendre beaucoup
de recul et je vais commencer par vous
poser une question quel est le rôle de
l'état à quoi sert-il quelle est sa
mission dans nos démocraties les états
existent pour garantir le bien commun
c'est à dire promouvoir pour chaque
citoyen comme vous comme moi les
conditions et les opportunités pour
qu'il vive la meilleure vie possible si
vous me permettez de faire un parallèle
avec le monde des affaires où l'on parle
d'expérience client ou bien avec le
monde du travail où l'on parle
d'expérience collaborateurs et bien le
devoir des états est d'offrir à leurs
citoyens
la meilleure expérience la meilleure
expérience citoyens et le concept que
l'on utilise dans les sphères
académiques et scientifiques pour
mesurer et analyser la qualité de
l'expérience vécue par un individu ce
concept qu'il existe et ça s'appelle le
bien-être
quand on fait référence aux conditions
objectives on parle de qualité de vie
par exemple le revenu la qualité de
l'air ou bien le niveau de sécurité de
l'endroit où l'on vit le bien-être lui
portent sur les conditions objectives et
aussi sur les conditions
subjectives le ressenti des citoyens
leur perception de la réalité
et puis quand les niveaux de bien-être
sont élevés eh bien on peut alors parler
de bonheur donc pour résumer ce que je
viens de vous dire la finalité des
gouvernements c'est d'améliorer le bien
être de leurs concitoyens
et ça c'est l'héritage précieux que nous
ont légué les philosophes des lumières
et il avait vu juste puisque pour 90%
des personnes
le bien-être représente ce qu'il ya de
plus important pour elle bien devant
d'autres notions comme le succès l'amour
ou même la santé et en même temps c'est
logique puisque le bien-être recours
toutes ces autres notions mais revenons
au rôle de l'état si vous le voulez bien
si en théorie cette idée d'assigner la
mission d'amélioration du bien-être vous
semble farfelue si vous croyez que ce
n'est pas le rôle de l'état
eh bien figurez-vous qu'en pratique
cette idée elle se vérifie en effet sur
les territoires où les niveaux de
bien-être sont bas et bien les citoyens
l'expriment et le sanctionne de leur
vote
au royaume uni les régions qui ont le
plus voté pour le break sites sont aussi
les régions qui présentent les niveaux
de bien être les plus bas et puis autre
exemple des chercheurs ont analysé les
résultats des élections en europe des
élections présidentielles de toutes les
élections présidentielles en europe
depuis 1970 et ils ont montré que la
réélection des gouvernements qui était
déjà en place
eh bien elle est beaucoup plus corrélé
au bien-être que à la croissance au
chômage ou encore à l'inflation
et ça la très grande majorité des femmes
et des hommes politiques ne l'a pas
encore assimilé au contraire il raisonne
toujours dans une logique de
maximisation de la croissance et de la
maximisation de
des richesses matérielles et sur cet
objectif
eh bien ils ont réussi depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale le pib n'a cessé de
croître alors que les niveaux de
bien-être eux n'ont pas bougé
et en plus de ça nous sommes en train
d'assister à une recrudescence inédite
de symptômes qui sont caractéristiques
du mal être psychologique
il y à une explosion de burn out de
dépression de troubles anxieux de stress
d'addiction et même de suicide plus 60%
en 50 ans dans le monde + 60 %
mais la bonne nouvelle parce qu'il y a
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il existe une
science du bien-être
depuis les années 70 des milliers et des
milliers et des milliers d'études
scientifiques ont été réalisés sur le
bien-être et ce dans des disciplines
très variées comme la psychologie la
sociologie l'économie et plus récemment
ce qu'on appelle l'économie
comportementale et puis les
neurosciences aussi et toutes ses
recherches elle nous apporte beaucoup de
valeur parce que pour la première fois
elles nous permettent de définir ce
qu'est le bien-être ça faisait quand
même trois mille ans qu'on y
réfléchissait elles nous permettent de
comprendre de quoi il relève de quoi il
dépend elles nous permettent de le
mesurer et ce de manière fiable
notamment en demandant aux personnes
comment elles se sentent ou à quel point
elles sont satisfaites de leur vie et
encore une fois je le répète on sait le
faire de manière fiable et puis enfin
elles nous permettent de comprendre
quels sont les bénéfices du bien-être
parce qu'il ya des bénéfices
aujourd'hui on sait que les personnes
qui se déclarent heureuse ou qu'ils sont
satisfaits de leur vie elles sont en
meilleure santé
elles sont plus productives et la
productivité c'est pas forcément un gros
mot on peut être productif dans son
travail
en six ans entend bien elles sont plus
créatives elles sont plus altruiste et
elles sont plus connectés et respectueux
de leur environnement bref que des
choses positives que des choses dont les
territoires ont besoin aujourd'hui et
toutes ces avancées scientifiques sur le
sujet du bien-être elles ont contribué à
mettre ce sujet sur le devant de la
scène et notamment dans les plus grandes
instances internationales en 2011 l'onu
a adopté une résolution invitant ses
pays membres à davantage prendre en
compte le bonheur et le bien-être dans
leur politique
et depuis cette année là depuis 2011
l'onu publie chaque année le rapport
mondial sur le bonheur que vous voyez à
l'écran alors ne cherchez pas la france
sur ce visuel parce qu'elle ne figure
pas dans le top 20 même son de cloche
chez l' ocde qui suggère à ses pays
membres et bien de se détacher du pib
pour suivre le bien-être de leurs
citoyens et l' ocde a montré l'exemple
en créant un indicateur qui est connue
qui s'appelle bel reiff index lave l
indice du vivre mieux en français et
cette dynamique elle se confirme aussi
au niveau des pays le royaume uni et ça
ça pourra en surprendre certains mais
c'est le pays qui est le plus en pointe
en matière d'intégration du bien-être
dans l'action publique
le royaume uni a mis à jour il y a tout
juste un mois
et pour la première fois en 15 ans ce
qu'on appelle le très joli greenbook le
csaj greenbook c'est le document
officiel qui explique comment évaluer
les politiques les programmes les
projets publics
au royaume uni c'est quelque chose
d'important et qu'est ce qu'ils ont
apporté comme modifications dans le
chase the green book
ils ont ajouté ceci l'évaluation
économique se base sur les principes de
l'économie du bien-être c'est à dire la
manière dont le gouvernement peut
améliorer la valeur sociale
ou autrement dit le bien-être et ça peux
simplement vous semblez être une phrase
dans un bouquin mais je vous assure que
le fait d'avoir rajouté sas a des
conséquences qui sont très importantes
c'est révolutionnaire dans une tout
autre mesure la ville de dubaï aux
émirats arabes unis
c'est carrément fixé comme vision
stratégique de devenir la ville la plus
heureuse du monde
alors oui j'entends des gens rigolaient
dans la salle vous pourrez vous dire oui
mais attend à dubaï aux émirats arabes
unis
il y à des minorités dont les libertés
sont bafouées ce qui est vrai mais en
même temps ils ont quand même le mérite
de cette fixé cet objectif est d'avoir
enclenché une réflexion sérieuse sur le
sujet et alors la france dans tout ça
quid de la france qu'est ce qu'on a
réalisé
qui va dans ce sens dans notre pays
mon silence était la hauteur du nombre
d'actions concrètes qui ont été
entreprises par les derniers
gouvernements de notre pays c'est à dire
aucune
alors effectivement il y a bien eu en
2009 le rapport de la commission
stiglitz mais qui n'est resté qu'un
rapport il y a bien eu en 2015 le vote
d'une loi qui oblige le gouvernement à
publier chaque année un rapport sur les
indicateurs de richesses économiques
sociaux et environnementaux
mais cela n'a en rien changé
l'orientation globale des politiques qui
sont mises en oeuvre
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour
améliorer les choses
qu'est ce que l'on peut faire pour
centrer davantage notre pays la france
sur le bien-être de ses citoyens
la première chose à faire c'est de se
doter d'un système de mesures qui
rendent fidèlement compte de l'évolution
globale du bien-être vous connaissez
l'adage ceux qui ne se mesurent pas
n'existe pas et c'est encore plus vrai
s'agissant d'un concept aussi abstrait
multifactorielle et dynamique que le
bien-être et l'indicateur de mesure du
progrès qui continuent de prévaloir
aujourd'hui c'est le pib sauf que le
problème avec le pib c'est qu'ils
mesurent l'activité économique d'un pays
alors que ce qui nous intéresse à nous
c'est pas de mesurer l'activité
économique mais c'est bien de savoir si
nos vies se sont améliorées ou pas est
donc face à cela de plus en plus
d'économistes propose d'adopter des
démarches de mesures qui prennent la
forme de tableaux de bord qui monitor
toutes les composantes du bien-être de
manière consolidée et ça c'est un
excellente outils d aide à la décision
pour orienter l'action publique vers le
bien-être
et ces démarches elles sont pas
uniquement nécessaire au plus haut
niveau d'autorité elles le sont
également
au niveau des collectivités locales je
pense aux régions et aux villes et c'est
ce que fait depuis environ un an le
driving placé index horoya au
royaume-uni encore une fois qui montre
comment se portent les collectivités
est-ce que leur niveau de bien-être sont
élevés ou bien est-ce que leur niveau de
bien-être sont bas
c'est ce que l'on fait aussi avec le
ministère du bonheur à lyon et ça j'en
suis très fier nous sommes en train de
concevoir un indicateur de mesure du
bien-être qui est similaire à ce que je
viens de vous montrer pour le nouveau
quartier de la confluence qui est un
quartier de lyon qui vient d'être
réaménagé et ce qu'il a de spécial cet
indicateur s'est il inclut les habitants
dans la co construction des domaines qui
vont être suivies les habitants ont leur
mot à dire sur ce qui compte pour eux et
ça c'est aussi révolutionnaire
deuxièmement ce qu'il faut faire c'est
de prioriser l'allocation des ressources
sur les domaines qui sont les plus
importants dans l'amélioration de la vie
des gens il s'agit en fait de prioriser
de privilégier les politiques les
programmes les projets qui présente le
meilleur rapport coût efficacité en
matière de bien-être
par exemple le facteur numéro un de
bien-être à l'échelle d'un territoire
c'est quoi votre avis c'est la pauvreté
c'est le chômage et les inégalités
c'est la santé mentale la santé mentale
dans les pays industrialisés 38% des
problèmes de santé presque un sur deux
sont liés à la santé mentale
c'est énorme et alors que la
quasi-totalité des maladies physiques
sont traitées elles sont prises en
charge
seulement une personne sur quatre qui
souffre d'un trouble d'ordre mental est
prise en charge non seulement c'est
injuste pour celles qui sont pas prises
en charge mais en plus ça crée beaucoup
de souffrance et beaucoup de
dysfonctionnements pour notre société
or il ya beaucoup d'études qui montrent
que et bien toutes ces personnes
pourraient être prises en charge et ce
avec un rapport coût efficacité qui est
très bon on estime même que le coût
total de cette prise en charge pourrait
être complètement compensé parce que les
maladies physiques qui découle des
maladies liées à la santé mentale et
bien elle n'existerait plus et donc on
n'aurait plus à les traiter
le deuxième facteur qui a un impact
significatif sur le bien-être à
l'échelle d'un pays d'un territoire
c'est l'éducation est votre avis là
aussi quel est l'aspect dans le
développement d'un enfant qui
influencent le plus son bien-être
quand il est enfant mais aussi qui va
influencer son bien-être une fois qu'il
sera adulte c'est quoi à votre avis ces
qualifications c'est à dire ses diplômes
son comportement ou sa santé
émotionnelle c'est sa santé émotionnelle
par conséquent si ce que l'on souhaite
c'est améliorer le bien-être dans notre
pays dans un territoire dans la société
et bien dans ce cas avant de transmettre
aux enfants des compétences des
connaissances techniques le rôle de
l'éducation devrait être de leur
apprendre à identifier et à gérer leurs
émotions ça c'est leur aiderait ça leur
aiderait ça les aiderait pardon à ses
enfants qui vont devenir adulte de
devenir des adultes résilient et qui
sont émotionnellement intelligente et il
ya deux manières d'agir pour ça
premièrement en proposant des formations
aux parents des formations la
parentalité
c'est ce que font beaucoup de pays
aujourd'hui en france il ya plein de
personnes qui deviennent parents sans
rien connaître à l'éducation des enfants
et encore moins à la santé émotionnelle
et est la psychologie du développement
ce que je dis c'est pas de leur faire
passer un master en psychologie mais au
moins de leur donner les bases
deuxièmement en proposant de manière
systématique dans nos écoles des
activités de développement des
compétences sociaux émotionnel c'est ce
que fait la finlande depuis plusieurs
décennies et ça marche très bien et
vous allez me dire que oui mais ça coûte
cher en fait figurez vous que la
finlande dépensent moins d'argent par
élève que la france est en plus devinez
quoi
la finlande c'est le pays européen qui
chaque année arrive en tête dans le
classement pisa le classement
international de la réussite scolaire et
oui c'est vrai les recherches montrent
que les enfants qui se sentent le mieux
à l'école ce sont aussi des enfants qui
réussissent le mieux académiquement et
qu'on ne vienne pas me dire que en
france ça va pas marcher parce qu'on est
français parce que la culture ça c'est
possible partout ça peut marcher chez
nous aussi ce que je viens de vous
montrer ce sont deux exemples de
politiques l'une en matière de santé
l'autre en matière d'éducation qui
améliore à la fois le bien-être des
citoyens tout en améliorant aussi le
fonctionnement global de la société du
pays du territoire et c'est là la
qualité unique du bien-être c'est une
fin en soi pour chacun d'entre nous et
en même temps c'est un formidable levier
de transformation pour les sociétés je
pourrais continuer à vous donner
d'autres exemples de politiques qui ont
des effets similaires en matière
d'environnement de cohésion sociale
d'économie ou bien de travail mais je
dois terminer la présentation j'ai pas
assez de temps en tout cas s'il ya une
chose que j'aimerais que vous reteniez
ce serait celle-là si nous voulons des
territoires qui vont bien et qui
fonctionne bien si nous voulons une
france qui va bien qui se sent bien et
qui fonctionne bien donnons une place
centrale au bien être dans l'action
publique
parce que quand les niveaux de bien-être
sont élevés cela signifie aussi que nos
principes fondateurs de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité de justice sont
respectées la solution elle existe elle
est opérationnelle et elle se trouve
devant nous et nous avons encore du mal
à considérer avec sérieux parce que nous
sommes influencés par des vieux schémas
qui ne cesse pourtant de montrer leurs
limites
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'aimerais
profiter de cette intervention ça va
être diffusée sur internet de d'en
profiter pour lancer un appel aux
gouvernements aux coûté aux côtés
d'autres acteurs de la société civile et
du monde académique de la recherche pour
qu'il engage une démarche honnête et
sérieuse qui concorde avec sa raison
d'être qui est l'amélioration du
bien-être de tous je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]